let me ask you about
staying in aliens for just a little
longer because i think it's
it's a good transition talking about
governments and human societies
do you think if a us government
or any government was in possession
of an alien spacecraft or of information
related to alien spacecraft they would
have the capacity structurally would
they have
the the processes
would they be able to uh
communicate that to the public
effectively or would they keep it secret
in the room
and do nothing with it both of uh to try
to preserve
military secrets but also because of the
incompetence that's inherent to
bureaucracies
or either
we can certainly see when certain things
become declassified 25 or 50 years later
that there were things that the public
might have wanted to know
that were kept secret for a very long
time for reasons of
at least supposedly national security um
which is also a nice source of plausible
deniability for
um people covering their ass for doing
things that would be problematic and um
other purposes
there are there's a scientist at
stanford
who supposedly got some material that
was
recovered from area 51 type area did
analysis on it using i believe electron
microscopy and a couple
other methods and came to the idea that
it was a nanotech alloy
um that was something we didn't
currently have the ability to do was not
naturally occurring
like so there i've heard some things and
again like i said i'm i'm not gonna
stand behind any of these because i
haven't done the level of study to
have high confidence um
i think what you said also about would
it be super low-tech alien
um craft like would they necessarily
move their atoms around in space or
might they do something more interesting
than that might they be able to
uh have a different relationship to the
concept of space or
information or consciousness or
one of the things that the craft
supposedly do is not only
accelerate and turn in a way that looks
non-inertial but also disappear
so there's a question as to like the two
are not necessarily mutually exclusive
and it could be possible to some people
run a hypothesis
that they create intentional amounts of
exposure as an invitation
of a particular kind um
who knows interesting field we tend to
assume
like seti that's listening out for
aliens out there
i've just been recently reading more and
more about gravitational waves and you
have
orbiting black holes that orbit each
other
they generate ripples in space time
on my uh for fun at night when i lay in
bed i think about what it would be like
to ride those waves
when they not not the low magnitude they
are
as it when they reach earth but get
closer to the black holes
because they'll basically be shrinking
and expanding us
in all dimensions including time
so it's actually ripples through space
time that they generate
why is it that you couldn't use that
as travels the speed of light
travels that it's a very weird thing to
say when you're
when you're uh morphing space time it's
it's a company
it's you could argue it's faster than
the speed of light
so so if you're able to communicate by
someone enough energy to generate black
holes and to orbit the
uh to force them to orbit each other why
not travel
as the ripples in space-time
whatever the hell that means somehow
combined with wormholes
so if you're able to communicate through
like we don't think of
gravitational waves are something you
can communicate with because the
the radio will be have to be the side a
very large
size and very dense but perhaps that's
it
you know perhaps that's one way to
communicate it's a very effective way
and that would explain
like we wouldn't even be able to make
sense of that of the physics that
results
in an alien species that's able to
control gravity at that scale
i think he just jumped up the kardashev
scale so far
you're not just harnessing the power of
a star but harnessing the power of
mutually rotating black holes um
i i that's way above my physics pay
grade to think about
including even uh
non-rotating black hole versions of
trans warp travel
um i think
you know you can talk with eric more
about that i think he has better ideas
on it than i do
my hope for the future of humanity
mostly does not
rest in the near term on our ability to
get to other habitable planets in time
and even more than that in the list of
possible solutions of
how to improve human civilization uh
orbiting black holes
is not in the on the first page for you
not on the first page
okay i bet you did not expect us to
start this conversation here
but i'm glad the places it went
you